as the West makes good on sanction
threats against Russia for supporting
Ukrainian rebels Moscow has punched back
hard right in the golden arches
threatening to ban the cheeseburger
Royale filet-o-fish and ice-cream
parfait Russia's consumer rights
watchdog filed a lawsuit against
McDonald's saying they found ecoli in
the chicken caesar wrap antibiotics in
the pre sliced cheese and understated
the calorie count in burgers and
milkshakes russia has mastered the art
of adopting strict health and safety
standards
just as geopolitical tensions flare up
for example they banned Georgian wine in
the run-up to a 2008 war with Tbilisi
smoked fish from Latvia when they voted
to adopt the euro and earlier this year
Polish pork and Ukrainian cheese when
Warsaw called the sanctions of Russia as
Kiev descended into civil